if you were starting from scratch
had no holdings in crypto
but could only bet in one place
btc versus
eth versus other you only get to pick
one which would you choose and why
ptc
btc why and the reason is everything
else is a is a technology company
whereas bitcoin has become almost like a
like an element like gold that's to say
the fact that bitcoin not only is the
first but it has the disappeared founder
it has because it has a disappeared
founder
it fits a certain kind of mentality
where because there's no leader you
don't feel like you're submitting to
somebody you don't feel like you're
submitting to somebody by buying gold
okay satoshi is who you make them out to
be the disappeared i mean one thing like
this is not how i think about money
typically but if you look on any dollar
bill there's
weird incantations there's like a
pyramid with like eyes on it and so on
most forms of bills they have like the
most famous people in the country on
them the branding exercise is actually
pretty important on this stuff right and
the thing is that you can separate out
the economic the ideological and the
technological right as i said it's a log
scale most people would consider me like
from the outside very similar to a
bitcoin maximus but you know
i'll give you two thoughts on that so
first is on the economics yes if i can
only buy one thing you just buy bitcoin
because
nothing competes with it
it is possible by the way now to be
clear do i think it's 100 chance of
discussing no i think it's possible that
there is some remaining security issue
associated with the code um
but what's interesting is square is now
doing something with decentralizing
mining and the fact that mining is being
driven out of china is actually good
because i don't think any other state
has the state capacity to do what china
did and the ruthlessness
so it's unlikely that there's going to
be a technical attack on bitcoin the
only thing that's going to happen
going forward is potentially a
regulatory or a software attack but
outside of that it's communities so
strong that can probably repair on that
regulatory attacks are also less likely
to kill it because the u.s is losing
control over the world if germany
defies on north stream 2 and if you know
sanctions don't affect germany anymore
it does doesn't affect india if el
salvador can go bitcoin some states will
have bitcoin be legal as well as within
the u.s so the federal government
doesn't have the veto so finally really
the technical attack is there some
possibility of some you know zero day
that can like inflate a lot of coins and
be hard to patch that's possible
it is still something where there's like
one one one client that is very popular
one bitcoin client it's not a
multi-client thing so that's like the
main weakness right now is it possible
there's some supply chain attack where
some library is included and it hasn't
been audited sufficiently yes
also quantum cryptography you know
that's kind of an unknown but is it
possible that say quantum decryption
becomes something that is out there
before quantum encryption that quantum
decryption is highly centralized and
some governments can do it or some
centralized actor can do it but quantum
encryption is not something everybody
has access to those are all
possibilities but the risk factor is
relatively low wanna be happy build a
life not just a business hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how you can start
investing in cryptocurrencies from
scratch
enjoy
rule number two sees the opportunity
with kevin o'leary a lot of people jump
when they think of crypto and public
companies to put bitcoin on the balance
sheet right and i think that there's
obviously some that have done it some
that will do it is there a middle ground
where this usdc strategy that you're
employing you'll see some public
companies start to do that as well and
it's merely a low risk volatile value
kind of high yield generation type
strategy from like a treasury management
rather than trying to jump straight from
us dollars to bitcoin
you know it's that's a great question
and that is the question well i do
questions
no no but that i'll tell you why that's
a great question because when you go to
the actual compliance departments of
large institutions and i've had many of
these dialogues just in the last you
know two weeks
can you convince your compliance
department that usdc
is not bitcoin
and that you should somehow get a pass
on usdc versus bitcoin and it shouldn't
be regulated in the same way and that's
where you have a lot of gray zone
because
you know you think about what it if
you're going to be on the treasury side
of your balance sheet let's say you're
managing you know 100 billion dollars of
cash and you want to put a 10 in usdc so
instead of getting 22 basis points you
can get 3.2 percent
and you go to compliance and say i'm
going to take this cash
and convert it to usdc and i'm going to
start writing contracts on it
what do you think the compliance
department is going to tell you they're
going to say
wait a second have we ever done this
before show me where
show me where you got the sign off on
that from the board show me where you
did the reporting not just internally on
the mark to market but you reported
successfully to the irs on the quarterly
and annual basis
the problem isn't that the product isn't
desired the problem is there's no
infrastructure for compliance yet you
know
and you know pop we're not talking about
small dough here we're talking about
hundreds of millions of dollars
moving fluidly off balance sheets into
these contracts and the only way you're
going to get that done is prove to
compliance and prove to the regulators
that you can do it in a way that you
stay on side so the good news is from
from a institutional guy in terms of my
thinking
what an opportunity what a huge huge
opportunity this is for somebody or me
or multiple platforms
to solve this
for the trillions of dollars that want
to use it rule number three do your
analysis with robot paul i kind of
figured out a long time ago as we all
have that there's a debt issue with the
world and that
you know when lehman went bust and
things like that happened nobody knew
who owned what and somebody introduced
me to blockchain back in 2012 and
bitcoin and i thought you know what this
could be the answer to all of this
so i started investing back then
and i wrote probably the first macro
paper on valuing bitcoin back in 2013
and i basically looked at it in the
stock to flow model versus gold and i
thought you know with gold at 1300 bucks
at the time bitcoin could be worth as
much as a million dollars which sounded
crazy because it was at 200 then
and um i bought it and i held it for a
few years and then sold it in the rally
in 2017 and then it had been on my radar
screen as things were evolving i'd
always said that the next financial
crisis the answer to any crisis is now
printing up more money and therefore
crypto and macro were going to meet
at the next crisis and it was going to
dawn on a lot of people that this
limited supply digital asset had true
value to create a new financial system
and had a store of value property even
though it was extremely and remains
extremely volatile
so 2020 comes along um and
march comes along and it sells off hard
and i realize that this is the
opportunities i've been waiting for so i
kind of started pounding the table and i
put
at that time i was still involved i had
a you know i had a fantastic bet in
bonds that you and i had spoken to euro
dollar futures stuff like that i was
long dollars you know all the usual kind
of macro stuff going into that and you
and i had spoken i think in bed or early
march pretty much about the same
opportunity set that we saw
but crypto started becoming a bigger
position because what i did is i started
looking at the chart of bitcoin against
other assets and i'm like holy sh it's
gonna break out versus everything
so
if this is the time and us macro guys
love
a
fast
trending volatile market because that's
where we make our money you know the
real money's made in bear markets for us
we grind it out in bull markets
so i see this see the opportunity and i
start building my position much more
because i'm thinking well i don't need
to end gold i don't need to own bonds i
don't need to earn equities that he said
anything just this asset
so that was that got me to about
september
2020
and then i noticed people attacking me
when i started saying ah ethereum looks
interesting i thought that's interesting
they're attacking me for liking
something else just like if i went to
you and said oh i like you know canadian
bonds versus us bonds you go how dare
you you can't talk about canadian people
it's like it's ridiculous so anyway so
so when people start doing that to me i
will go and do the work on it and figure
out are they right or or is there some
crowd
illogic going
on so i started looking at ethereum but
yeah it looks interesting you know i
always start with the charts
my way of framing what the market's been
doing and how it feels and the
psychology
and then i start doing work on something
called metcalfe's law
and that is basically
a way of analyzing these networks
whether it's mobile phone networks the
internet amazon facebook when you look
at the number of nodes on the network
and the interconnection of the nodes
the more of those two things the more
valuable it is
so i plotted out kind of
active wallets and a few other things
and did a nice regression line on it and
it was perfect fit with price
and i'm like oh my god
so then i started looking at bitcoin and
ethereum and all of the other assets
digital assets and they're all the same
i'm not okay so this is the narratives
that are around about store of value and
and um
whatever it may be the the um the
internet computer all of this
those narratives are driving those
communities but the reality is they were
being driven by metcalfe's law and they
were all the same thing once i
understood that i could now understand
the space where i could start looking
for network adoption effects and the
moment i opened those eyes i realized
that
ethereum had a much larger faster
network adoption than bitcoin was having
and i actually started switching my
portfolio again everybody hated me for
it i then started buying a bunch of
other coins tokens stuff i didn't really
know a lot about so i just took a small
weighting like 20 percent and of my
portfolio which is now 100 correct and
has been for quite a while now since
maybe may last year um and so i bought a
basket saying i'm an idiot i don't
really understand any of this stuff but
i want to see how it trades yeah and
and then starting then you start to
figure out okay what are the macro bets
within this space that i want to take
where is this future going
then we have defy nfts all of these
things explode over the last 12 months
and you're seeing adoption explode
so my framework is built around
metcalfe's law adoption understanding
this is community driven
it actually charts pretty well as well
um and i i personally
can't short-term trade it it's too
extremely volatile assets are good for
really short-term super short-term
traders but i'm not that guy you know my
time horizon is three months to 18
months so i just stuck it on and left it
and i've done nothing with it all i've
done is add um and you know i've tweaked
it around a bit moving some assets
around
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four get your share of
wealth with tom bilyeu i legitimately
want to with all the caveats of you have
to be so careful you cannot go blindly
into this
but i can think of few things that are
worth people's time and energy to
understand more than the blockchain and
that if this were a baseball game we are
still in the locker room getting ready
to come out onto the field
it's like because i mean that from a
technology standpoint like even forget
just that you could buy bitcoin or
ethereum or whatever today and it will
go up in value
what's going to be built on the back of
the technology will create a world that
will be as unrecognizable as a
post-internet world would have been to
me in you know 93 before i'd even heard
of email to now i mean that's utterly
just it's a transformation that i could
never predicted
it's going to be the same thing but this
one's happening in full view because we
already have the internet so it's
already you and i are talking right now
to you know hopefully millions of people
and then on top of that
it's
we've all seen it happen before so you
can say hey guys remember mobile phones
hey guys remember the internet this is a
big one like that
and so
i think this is going to be
i'm going to make a statement and you're
going to say whether i'm a fool or not i
think this will be the biggest wealth
transfer ever that we've ever seen like
robber baron moment type wealth transfer
but it it's not going to go to a really
really small number of people it's going
to go to whoever the
takes the time to learn about this and
go there's some percent percentage of my
daily income doesn't like it it will go
to people who don't even think in net
worth terms yet
because this is as raoul paul said this
is the first time in human history where
the average person has been able to
front run the institutions so this is a
chance for people to get ten dollars
every paycheck whatever rule number five
change your mind with anthony pompliano
in the beginning all the legacy players
wanted nothing to do with this and a lot
of my time was focused on bitcoin
because that was really the only liquid
true asset they would even have a
conversation about
all the billionaire investors not
interested all the big wall street banks
not interested all the
you know institutional investors not
interested
almost
to a t
the best in the world
have changed their mind
they continued to get new information
and they changed their mind
and now some of them are the largest
investors in the industry
and so there's a level of intelligence
and intellectual humility it takes to
get new information and change your mind
the people who haven't changed their
mind for the most part not everyone but
for the most part
historically they have been very good
investors that's interesting and so they
just have this rigid
way of thinking
and regardless of the technology
evolution regardless of what happens in
the market they just have that rigid you
know kind of adherence to a framework
and so to me like that's been one of the
biggest investing lessons is
i talked to that guy
he wasn't like he gave me a 12-minute
meeting he literally
nice to meet you i basically took the
meeting because somebody else i know
told me i should meet with you but like
i gotta go to lunch right
to now you're a huge investor in this
stuff and you're out and you're talking
about it and you're explaining it to
people et cetera
into you what happened
oh
you're not religious about your
ideas you're not religious about
uh having to be right
instead he said no it reached a point
where it was very obvious that the
macroeconomic environment was going to
continue to be crazy people were going
to want to hold this asset i understood
how it worked and so i changed my mind
by the way i've been an idiot if i
didn't change my mind rule number six
invest in appreciating tokens with
michael saylor what does the transition
look like to make it into something like
the strongest currency we've got the us
dollar dominance as a currency how does
bitcoin
transition
do you think it will
i think bitcoin as the network is going
to continue to grow and it's going to
demonetize other assets
and that the assets it's going to
demonetize will be a function of the
cultures that it's within so for example
in a culture
where you have hyperinflation and the
government collapses
it's going to demonetize the currency
because everybody desperately needs a
currency and there isn't an alternative
um
in a culture where people
people feel
it's unsafe to own property
like for example if you had weak
property rights
and you felt like the government was
going to seize your house or seize your
land or you couldn't own land
maybe it's illegal to own land then
bitcoin's going to demonetize the
property
like if you have a million dollars
you're not going to invest it and land
if you don't trust your property rights
i have for example like
i wouldn't be comfortable making an
investment in an apartment building in a
city that has shown itself willing to
strip landlords of their rights right
right so you're holding an apartment
building you can't you can't charge your
your uh tenants to live in the apartment
building nor can you evict them
okay what's the what's the logical value
of the building does it go up or does it
go down in that circumstance and if i
have if i have discretionary cash
am i going to reinvest it in more
apartment buildings or not
i think the answer is
wherever we see property impaired the
monetary energy and the property is
going to flow to an alternative which is
better
so in the u.s
i think that that in the u.s people are
comfortable with the us dollar and what
they're not comfortable with or less
comfortable with is maybe
uh risky stocks
or or risky property investments or say
gold
things like that and so it's logical
that bitcoin
strips the monetary premium from
commodities securities indexes
credit like like for example i got a
million dollars and i could invest it in
30-year t-bills yielding 1.6
or i could buy bitcoin well
you know what's going to happen there is
i
my company had a lot of that right we
we had
we would normally put 90 of our treasury
into sovereign debt
and only 50 million of it or 10 of it
was sitting in cash
so
what we did is we demonetized the
sovereign debt for the most part and we
rolled into bitcoin so i think in the in
the developed world in europe and the us
i think that that bitcoin is going to
demonetize
uh debt
low grade debt or or low yielding debt
and credit it's going to demonetize
savings accounts but i mean it's
most people had already given up on
savings accounts by the time we got the
last year what they go to etfs
and so i think bitcoin actually grabs uh
monetary energy or capital from etfs
from commercial real estate
and from debt
in the developed world i think in the uh
in the developing world
and you know in places like
iran even in china and north korea and
in lebanon in syria and iran and iraq
and afghanistan and lots of places like
that well
you don't have a stable banking system
you're not even dollarized
your currency is much worse than that
right
so i think that
i think that uh what you're gonna see is
that if there's
180 countries or something out there i
think that 15 or 20 of them keep their
currency privileges i think the bottom
100
are going to lose their currencies i
think they're going to dollarize first
everybody wants to but how do i
dollarize the best way to dollarize is
the el salvador strategy which is
i have a mobile application which has
got dollars and it's got bitcoin on a
lightning network
uh what you want is you want a currency
as a medium of exchange it's like a
stable value coin
stable versus all of the pricing of the
retailers
and that's like a dollar it's probably
the most stable thing in the universe
and then you want an asset which is an
appreciating
appreciating uh token
that will will hold its value over time
and that's bitcoin
and if you wanted to maximize your
utility you would
you kind of put 90 of your balance sheet
into the asset
into bitcoin
and then you put the last piece the
working capital or the checking account
into whatever is the currency
uh that most of the retailers that
you're surrounded with take so if i was
in japan
i'd be holding one month worth of yen
and if i was in italy i'd be holding one
month worth of euro and if i'm in the
u.s or a dollar economy i'm holding one
month worth of dollars
and then the rest i'm sweeping and to
enter my long-term asset portfolio or
property portfolio and my stock of
property is
you know i maybe i buy a property to
live in because it's a nice house and i
want to live in it for the rest of my
life and i can't rent it
maybe
then maybe i buy my trophy art or you
know maybe i buy the picture because i
love the picture or maybe i buy the car
or maybe i buy the boat or maybe i buy
the plane or something because i want to
fly in it float in it live in it
whatever i want to do
but all my discretionary
asset i would put into the highest
quality property which is of course
bitcoin and rule number seven the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is take control with mark cuban it's the
whole concept of decentralization and
fighting the man right it's like it's
all about governance wsb investors game
stock amc et cetera they want to govern
themselves they don't want to be
dictated to by anybody else and so you
know wall street bets is its own form of
governance and voting you know they're
all staking in their own little way
sometimes you may stake great
information you know a research report
you wrote and you let it ride and see
what kind of returns you can get but
when you have all these validators
effectively who have staked if you know
they bought gme or amc that's their
staking right and they're maybe i'm
getting all the terminology around
because i'm just learning some of it but
they're they're staking it and then
they're about becoming validators right
and that validation is them buying the
the um the stock and you know just
repeating it as much as possible and you
know getting diamond hands and hodling
you know which however you want to call
it and you know
that's that's decentralization and
that's the whole underpinning of
blockchain and crypto you know
let's take control of our own destiny
and it's not 100 right because some
applications are centralized and some
players pretend they're decentralized
and they're not yada yada and that goes
back to your narratives a lot of people
create bs narratives but um in reality
when it all comes down to it it is
analogous simply because
the
it's decentralized and it's giving power
to validators and that's what this
that's the market needed
portability bitcoins pure information it
can move at the speed of light can't get
much faster than that
uh recognizability refers to
the ability to verify the veracity of
the money or its authenticity so you can
actually
when we used to transact gold
there were time honored techniques for
verifying that it was gold and not
gold-plated lead for instance this is
where we get the term sound money a gold
coin made a very particular sound when
dropped from a certain height you know
you've seen people buying coins these
are all techniques for testing
uh the authenticity of gold and with
bitcoin we have something unique in that
if you're running a full node you can
verify that the bitcoin is bitcoin right
it cannot be
uh tampered with it cannot be faked
and in addition to that as a node
operator you can audit the total supply
of bitcoin at any time which is unlike
any money in history so
you know with full certainty if you're
holding
1000 bitcoin you have 1 000 out of a
possible 21 million forever you have a
guaranteed fraction of the total supply
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want to see the
master class compilation we did on
crypto investing check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there so what's bitcoin well bitcoin is
the strongest asset the human race has
ever invented it's like gold with none
of the defects of gold so define what
the defects are why why is it the
greatest